sont des crimes de guerre ils seront
jugés par le monde entier comme un
génocide vous êtes ici avec moi vous
pouvez voir ce qu'il s'est passé et
sniper l'auront tous tirent une balle
dans la tête par l'ennui c'est comme ça
qu'ils s'amusaient
je n'ai pas vu de soldats russes tirer
sur quelqu'un je ne veux pas mentir mais
les gens le disent sinon pourquoi y
aurait-il tant de cadavres dans les rues
les militaires russes ils ont
complètement quitté la ville le 31 mars
à cette même date le maire de bush a
déclaré solennellement que tout était
réglé résidence deux jours plus tard
nous avons vu cette mise en scène dans
les rues qui est maintenant utilisé pour
miner la russie ce que nous avons vu du
régime de vladimir poutine dans l' usage
de munitions sur des civils innocents
constitue déjà à mon avis un crime de
guerre c'est un crime affreux c'est un
crime à supportable c'est un crime
ignoble mais en plus pour lui c'est
vraiment
salir l'image de la russie i know i say
say say je ne comprends pas le meurtre
de civils est un crime de guerre ça
change de vont enquêter sans relâche sur
ces crimes commis par les forces armées
royales j'exige que les organisations
internationales dans les contrats tissé
assaisonne source documenté des
atrocités dont il est clair qu'il ya des
indices aujourd'hui très claire de
crimes de guerre c'est l'armée russe qui
était à butch et donc nous avons
d'ailleurs marqué notre disponibilité
aux autorités ukrainiennes de les
assister dans les enquêtes qu'elles sont
en train de faire la justice
internationale doit passer nous allons
faire tout notre possible qu'il est
mieux pour que ceux qui ont perpétré ces
crimes de guerre ne soit pas impunie et
comparaissent devant la cour pénale
internationale
c'est pour répondre de crimes contre
l'humanité divin et pourquoi ne pas le
dire que nous et génocide dès le début
j'ai dit vladimir poutine était un
dictateur dès le début j'ai dit qu'il
s'était couché c'est un criminel de
guerre juridiquement c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant de le qualifier de criminels
de guerre de fait
s'il se déplace dans un autre pays
signataires
de ce traité de rome et de cette cour
pénale internationale ils peuvent être
arrêtés qui va aller le chercher c'est
une c'est un pays nucléaire vous
comprenez ça vous croyez que c'est un
pays comme ça du tiers-monde qu'on va
aller prendre traîné devant la cour
pénale on le laisse faire nous avons des
extrêmes et moore le pen mélenchon qui
ont vis-à-vis de poutine une indulgence
coupable qui les discrédite pour
présider la france à moins de vingt
jours de l'élection de yannick jadot à
la présidence de huy
[Musique]
après ce qui est arrivé à chris rock
avec will smith quand il ya un petit
plus grands moi
je préfère
il faudra mériter la nationalité
française
pendant ce temps il ya une bouteille
d'eau si vous avez besoin
vgp adverse pendant la bouteille
ensemble nous pouvons démentir ces
sondages partiel partiaux et leurs
commentateurs
oh mais pas on vas tu très vite un nom
s'attire les foudres d'une partie de la
salle nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]
je ne voulais pas je ne voulais
absolument pas cette réaction bien au
contraire s'il ya eu au début du meeting
quelques électeurs triste passé la
réalité voilà
[Musique]
mais il n'y a pas plus puissant que la
force tranquille de la fraternité
dans le combat climatique
le combat du siècle nos vies leur vie
valent plus que tous les français